Hello everybody, this is Dr. Kevin Connors and we are going to go over and it's the PUD1
genetic pathway and how it relates to cancer because it's just really cool.
So I know a lot of our patients have PUD1 defects and we do want to address those defects.
So when we look at your genetic pathway and we put it into our software, the PUD1 pathway
is what I'm talking about right here and I'm addressed to you that the PUD1 pathway is the main
pathway where you get rid of pesticides and insecticides, heavy metals, things like that but it's also
a pathway that helps you get rid of oxidizing agents, free radicals, are also the PUD1 pathway
is really important for much studies in the past have been the PUD1 pathway in heart disease
and we're going to just touch on that as well. So how it relates to cancer and heart disease
is important, it's an antioxidant, so peroxidase 1, the PUD1 gene makes an enzyme and that enzyme
does some really cool things in our body in order to prevent cancers, prevent cell membrane
destruction, prevent how different free radicals block apoptosis. The PUD1 pathway gets rid of that
so that's what cancer is, remember a cell that's not able to go into apoptosis that has damaged
cell membrane and cell membrane receptor, so apoptosis is stimulated and so it ties with cancer
directly. So I'm going to be pointing out some different studies, there's multiple studies that
will look at through this that point to exactly what I'm suggesting, this particular study has to do
with lung cancer and the progression of lung cancer when a person has a lot of PUD1 defects, so
like I said prior to some of the research that's just been coming out in the last few years,
mainly PUD1 had to do most of the studies were on cardiovascular disease because I know this is
a very complicated picture here, but if you could look at this, your cholesterol and low density
lipoproteins, particularly the large ones, are blocked from causing oxidation in the cell through the
PUD1 pathway, this is the PUD1 pathway right here in the PUD1 enzyme, it is given to the endothelial cell,
so sorry, this is a picture of these are your endothelial cells, the single layer cell that
lied your arteries, this is the lumen of an arterial vessel, so this is the lumen of the vessel that
blood is going through. The importance of high density lipoproteins, HDLs, is that they carry on it
the PUD1 enzyme, that that is distributed into the space that what's called the intimal lighting
of the blood vessel, that space that's right behind the endothelial cells, the lighting, this is the
lighting of the blood vessel, the HDL brings the PUD1 enzyme through that lighting, through the
endothelial cell spaces, and the biggest thing that the PUD1 enzyme does is it blocks the
oxidation of LDLs, so it literally helps block heart disease, so PUD1 pathways, but a lot of
studies on PUD1 pathway and how it blocks heart disease, now if I have a bunch of defects on my
PUD1 enzymes and my PUD1 genes, I'm not going to be making a lot of that PUD1 enzyme, so I'm going to
have deficiencies, you could say like this person is going to have a greatly reduced PUD1 enzyme
production, their risk for cardiovascular disease, just talking about this line with
cardiovascular disease, now we're going to be talking about kids who are just a second,
is going to be greatly increased, this person's got a lot of defects on their PUD1 enzyme,
so we could go through each one of these different things that it's just amazing, what is taking place
inside the intimal of the lighting of each of your arteries through all your blood vessels,
and what it does to this pathway, and what oxidized LDL does with the foam cell production,
how it attracts different things, and that's what causes all sorts of problems, so
making PUD1 enzyme is super important for heart disease, that's why I want you to get off of this
slide, not to be so complicated, but it's really important, well PUD1 deals a lot with oxidative stress,
so reducing oxidative stress is important for kids or patients, that's why we talk about the
glutathione pathway, and the superoxide disputease pathway, but PUD1 also plays a huge part in
decreasing oxidative stress, which is the main cause of cancer, you got a lot of excess superoxide
ions, and you have proxiedite rate formation, remember whenever we talk about proxiedite
rate formation, we talk about back here, and what it's doing to the blood vessels, so it's causing
heart disease, but it's also causing cancer, because of that oxidative stress piece, so this particularly,
particular study published in 2011 in molecular and cellular biology, was talking about the PUD1
Q-1.92 R-G-D in particular, so it was only talking about this G-D here, and that's all they did
the study on, so when we look at your genes, we're looking at all your PUD1 genes, so yes,
this gene important, yeah, but it's not any more important or less important to these other ones,
this is just the one that they did the study on, so that one, having a defect of that increases your
cancer risk, here's a study about bladder cancer, oh by the way this was on breast cancer,
this is on bladder cancer, same thing, a study does this increase your susceptibility to bladder
cancer, the answer is yes, another study talking about prostate cancer, this is looking at some of
your cytochrome P450 pathway, and your glutathione recycling pathway with PUD1, and it increases the
risk of prostate cancer, we could go on increase risk of Don Hodgkin's lymphoma, so I could go on and
on, we could list a whole bunch of studies, but it's increased risk for multiple different type
of different lines of cancer with the PUD1 pathway defects, so having defects on that pathway,
increase cancer risk, because it decreases your ability to get rid of superoxid ions, free radicals,
proxy nitrate, any free radicals that they're going to damage the cell that are going to block the
capsaic pathway, which is the apoptosis pathway, both the intrinsic and the extrinsic apoptosis pathway
can be blocked when you have free radicals, so that's what PUD1 does, it's diminishing reactive
oxygen species, this is talking mainly about foam cells again with heart disease, but this is happening
at every single cell, so PUD1 is the good guy that we need to protect, when we have defects on that PUD1
pathway, we need to support it, remember these are genetic defects, we're not going to make these go away,
so you pull up some studies, how can you support the PUD1 pathway? Really interesting study here
in nutrients 2015, they found that a mediterranean diet increased the PUD1G or the PUD1 enzyme,
so even if a person has defects, genetic defects on the PUD1 pathway, a mediterranean diet increased
the PUD1 enzyme production, and really what the hypothesis was, it was the olive oil in the
mediterranean diet, plus you typically need a mediterranean diet, you're need a good whole foods,
so it was the olive oil and the oleatic acid in the olive oil, so where could you get that?
Well, you could get that by using olive leaf extract also, so olive leaf extract, which is in our
miracle mix number two product, that's a big piece of our miracle mix number two, and it wasn't
because of this study, it was because of other studies with cancer that I put that in there,
so but using olive oil as one of your fats increases PUD1, so there's a dietary thing,
corseted, pomegranate, and extantis and also increases PUD1 production, the enzyme production,
these are three products that are purposely put in the product PUD1 accelerator, so if people have
a lot of PUD1 pathway defects, we could support it using the PUD1 assist is what the product is called,
PUD1 assist that's in our store, or the medicinal product, our miracle mix number two,
has the olive leaf extract in it, so that's what we want to support, we want to support the production
of PUD1 enzyme, and that's going to help people with cancer, so that's what our goal in with that is,
of course you got to do genetic testing to find out if I have a PUD1 G defect in the first place,
that's why we do that genetic testing with cancer patients, so I try to cruise through this really
quick you guys because I know this is stale information for most of you to find as exciting as I do,
but it can be extremely helpful for you to understand why I'm actually asking you to take a product
when you have a defect, so taking not just giving you or trying to sell a product, we're trying to
support this pathway that isn't working very well, and that pathway is pretty important, so I'm
trying to get it into your mind why you're doing what you're doing and what we're looking for,
so if you look back at your genetic chart and you have a bunch of PUD1 defects and we're not
addressing it, make sure you call our office so we jump on that we start looking at that,
there may be some reasons why I didn't put you on a product, all right, hopefully that helps,
and we will talk to you very soon, you can check out any other videos at our website and
challenge you to get your genetics looked at so we can look at this a little deeper. Thanks Dr. Cutters,
have a good day.